oh gosh breaking news bringing you about
the travel restrictions between
the uk and europe our chief political
correspondent john craig
is in westminster for us john what can
you tell us
good news uh we can now confirm uh that
the cabinet's
covid operations committee has decided
today
uh that uh the uk borders are going to
be opened up to uh
travelers from the eu european union and
the united states
so it means the tourists business people
family members
from america can come to the uk without
having to quarantine
for two weeks which was the previous
rule um
that was widely expected that this
decision was going to happen
number of reasons the chancellor has
been pushing for it for business reasons
transatlantic travel has been hit been
hit
um airlines like ba virgin atlantic but
also the prime minister has been
concerned
that since the european union relaxed
its rules to allow
uh uh eur americans to come to europe
uh that the uk was being left behind
that a lot of tourists would be going to
paris rome rather than london
we don't know the date this is going to
happen could be as early as next week
the 1st of august is
sunday but this will be widely welcomed
by those family members who have not
seen
relatives from the states for 15 16
months or so
and it is a climb down by the british
government
uh it was described as reckless by
angela rainer here on sky news earlier
uh also speaking on sky news earlier
therese coffey the cabinet minister
said this move had been discussed by the
prime minister and uh president biden
at the g7 summit well that's the good
news the bad news
of course is that uh rules brought in by
president trump
uh preventing uh british people from
traveling to the us
um without uh severe restrictions they
have not yet been lifted but it is
entirely possible
we may hear something from the american
government earlier today we learned
another climb down by the uk government
that's that
uh from the 16th of august fully people
who've been fully vaccinated
won't be required uh to take a test
if they come into contact with someone
uh with covid
um unless they have symptoms
um that's of course uh that is a change
too previously you had to take a test so
good news
uh for uh travelers uh people with
family in america who want them to come
over and visit
good news for people on the ping demik
as well
we are hoping to hear from grant schapps
the transport secretary more details
possibly the date when this travel
change is going to come in could be as
early
as next week uh beginning of august
there's no doubt be criticism from the
travel industry if
it's not until the 16th of august but
probably uh
there's a good chance it could be the
beginning of august